el acuerdo energético por el que catar
enviará a Alemania hasta 2 millones de
toneladas de gas natural licuado al año
por un periodo de 15 años forma parte de
la estrategia de las autoridades
alemanas de diversificar sus fuentes de
energía desde que comenzó la guerra en
Ucrania una guerra que reveló que
confirmó la muy profunda dependencia que
tenía Alemania de Rusia en particular
del gas Ruso y que según analistas es
una de las causas principales del actual
crisis económica y energética que se
vive en Alemania y en Europa quienes ven
de manera positiva a este acuerdo con
Qatar consideran que se trata
precisamente de un paso hacia esa
diversificación energética pero también
a quienes lo ven de manera crítica por
ejemplo por el período de 15 años que
algunos consideran largo pero también
Por quienes ven en este acuerdo un
ejemplo de doble moral de parte de
Alemania por un lado las autoridades
alemanas han criticado a Qatar por el
respeto a los derechos humanos y no
comparten muchos valores con las
autoridades de ese país pero por el otro
lado firman acuerdos millonarios con
Qatar